[Musica]
sono nato a rontagnano un piccolo paese
di campagna non lontano da cesena uno
dei momenti che attendevo di più nella
mia famiglia era la domenica sera quando
mia madre preparava la piadina
io mi mettevo li assistere al rito lei
che prendeva la farina la setacciava
apriva un cratere
dentro questa montagnetta e poi versava
l'acqua un cucchiaio distrutto un
pizzico di sale è un pochino di
bicarbonato poi impastava e preparava
l'impasto che poi lo lasciamo riposare
per un'oretta coperto dentro da un
canovaccio e poi tagliava la prima
fretta la stendeva col matterello e
l'appoggiava finalmente sulla teglia di
terracotta ovviamente sulla stufa a
legna ed io ad aspettare finalmente di
poter prendere la prima fetta
anticipando tutti gli altri che intanto
aspettavano in cucina però gli anni sono
passati veloci e all'improvviso mi sono
trovato a cesena al liceo scientifico a
mangiare una piadina in un chiosco
insieme ai miei due compagni
marco riminese e roberta che è di
ravenna e così sono cominciate le
discussioni marco ha iniziato dire ma la
piadina che ha fatte cesena è troppo
piccola deve essere estesa molto di più
e poi ci devono essere le bolle in
superficie deve essere sottile
poi arriva roberta che ravennate dice
beh allora perché nella piadina ci va il
latte e poi si va al miele allora
anch'io che sono i più timido del gruppo
non resisto e dico ma no ci vanno di
carbonato e gli altri mi guardano ma sei
pazzo così la piadina diventa gialla e
siamo andati avanti così per anni a
discutere su quale fosse la vera piadina
poi ci si è messo anche samuele bersani
che in una nota canzone tira fuori una
fantomatica piadina che vorrebbe
esportare in iran
e così nascono tante piadina nel
frattempo nasce quella vegetariana con
l'olio extravergine al posto dello
strutto nasce e quella per celiaci ma si
è quella con la farina di canapa ma
finalmente nel 2013 l'unione europea
riconosce la piadina come alimento
tipico ad indicazione geografica
protetta e stabilisce la ricetta quella
vera quella originale farina acqua
strutto olio extravergine d'oliva a
scelta sale ed eventuale aggiunta gli
agenti lievitanti il bicarbonato come
faceva mia mamma e poi questo in realtà
ha dato la possibilità di trasferire la
piadina ad una produzione di tipo
industriale ed oggi troviamo la piadina
commercializzata nei banchi della grande
distribuzione confezionata sottovuoto e
la troviamo anche sotto forma di
surgelato ma veramente questo tipo di
piadina la piadina vegetariana la
piadina gluten free sono ancora alimenti
tradizionali un alimento tradizionale
per essere definito tale deve essere
stato prodotto in una determinata area
geografica per un lungo tempo e
soprattutto deve essere entrato a far
parte del patrimonio culturale della
storia della vita delle persone che
abitano questa area geografica ma sapete
questa è la definizione ma un conto è
una definizione
un conto è quello che noi percepiamo e
la nostra percezione è che gli alimenti
tradizionali siano tutti di origine
contadina e questo in realtà nella
maggioranza dei casi non è vero perché
gli alimenti tradizionali sono stati
inventati per gli aristocratici che
vivevano per lo più nelle cittá e quindi
un esempio ci viene incontro di nuovo
prendendo dalla tradizione della cucina
romagnola i cappelletti cappelletti si
si pensa che siano stati inventati nel
cinquecento nelle corti signorili e solo
dopo si siano diffusi nelle campagne
dove però il consumo dei cappelletti era
limitato ai giorni di festa ed
ovviamente essendo in romagna
i cappelletti vanno serviti col brodo di
cappone sennò che natale e vallo a dire
ai bolognesi che nel brodo di cappone ci
metto di tortellini
va beh e parlando di cappone non resisto
e pensando sempre agli anni del liceo mi
viene in mente renzo tramaglino che è
costretto a portare i quattro capponi
che agnese aveva per mesi curato ed
allevato per il banchetto di nozze ad
azzeccagarbugli che il cappone se lo
poteva permettere quasi tutti i giorni
renzo tramaglino no e poi pensiamo che
gli alimenti quelli tradizionali siano
derivanti da una ricetta unica che non è
mai cambiata
e questo non è vero pensiamo un altro
piatto della tradizione romagnola le
tagliatelle con il ragù oggi nel ragù
usiamo il pomodoro ma il pomodoro
ovviamente è stato introdotto sono molto
successivamente quando dopo la scoperta
dell'america
quando il pomodoro è stato portato in
europa e del cibo prediletto degli
aztechi era guardato con sospetto perché
era ritenuta una pianta velenosa
pericolosa e quindi veniva tenuta solo
come pianta ornamentale e poi invece
sappiamo come è diventato importante per
la cucina italiana è un altro aspetto a
volte ci sfugge che gli alimenti
tradizionali sono il frutto di una
stratificazione delle colture e quindi
viene in mente la salsiccia luganega che
oggi riteniamo essere tipica delle zone
che comprendono la zona che comprende
fra la lombardia e il veneto invece la
sua origine è contenuta già nel suo nome
infatti varrone un militare romano anche
un letterato scrive che una salsiccia
fatta con l'intestino crasso del maiale
la lucanica i soldati romani l'hanno
imparato a fare dai lucani ma i lucani
l'hanno imparato a fare dai greci che
popolavano le coste meridionali della
nostra penisola che a loro volta l'hanno
imparato a fare dai fenici che si
suppone si unì vero inventore
degli insaccati ma chissà e questa è la
storia di todi tanti alimenti
tradizionali non solo della piadina days
cappelletti della tagliatelle con il
ragù e quindi ci dobbiamo rassegnare che
in realtà è il risultato di
un'evoluzione che ha visto innumerevoli
cambiamenti che sono stati necessari in
relazione all'evoluzione nel tempo
stesso è molto spesso infatti tendiamo a
confondere il termine tradizione con
naturale ci viene facile in realtà se ci
pensiamo bene lo sappiamo lo sappiamo
molto bene che non tutti gli alimenti
che ci vengono dalla natura sono buoni
pensiamo ai bellissimi funghi velenosi
che popolano le favole ma pensiamo anche
alla salsiccia che in passato
rappresentava un rischio molto elevato
per le persone perché si poteva
sviluppare un microorganismo il botulino
che produce una tossina che può
addirittura portare alla morte delle
persone e oggi invece possiamo evitarlo
grazie al fatto che abbiamo acquisito
conoscenze che ci permettono di
controllarlo e quindi che destino devono
avere per noi questi alimenti
tradizionali li dobbiamo innovare si
allora come facciamo trovare un
compromesso allora a mio parere
innanzitutto ci dobbiamo liberare da
questa idea di naturalità e sgombrare
anche il campo dal fatto di essere
rigidi nel considerare un unica origine
unica ricetta come ho cercato di
dimostrare con gli esempi che vi ho
fatto e quindi in realtà andare oltre
andare a ricercare l'essenza il valore
di questi alimenti tradizionali che va
al di là di questi concetti e questo è
importante sia a livello individuale di
gruppo di consorzio di tutela di
istituzione cioè in realtà dobbiamo
riappropriarci di questi alimenti
tradizionali ma cosa vuol dire
riappropriarcene vuol dire fare i conti
con le generazioni che ci hanno
preceduto e quindi secondo me
in realtà il tema più importante che sta
dietro la modalità con cui dobbiamo
accogliere questi alimenti tradizionali
e il tema dell'eredità l'eredità di ciò
che ci deriva dal passato dalla cura dal
sapere delle generazioni che ci hanno
preceduto
e chi è il buon e rete chi è il buon
erede l'erede giusto è colui che lavora
su ciò che ha ricevuto ma riconoscendo
il debito che deve le generazioni
precedenti e deve assumersi la
responsabilità ma soprattutto la libertà
di generare nuovi frutti ed è per questo
che quando torno a trovare mia madre
la trovo ancora a prepararmi la piadina
a compiere gli stessi gesti capisco solo
ora che in realtà ho imparato molto di
più dai suoi gesti che non
dall'inimitabile sapore della sua
piadina e allora oggi io mi sento il
peso e la responsabilità di trasferire
questo sapere di trasmetterlo a mia
figlia
ai miei studenti ai miei allievi e anche
a voi
grazie